i'm here with emily blood give it up
in honor of her new movie a quiet place
too which airs
in theaters may 28th it's time to play a
game called a quiet case
oh yes i had never
heard of that it was very sexy jesse
nice
nice i'm going to be she was about to do
she was with the duke just then in her
head that's what she said always
first we need hosts everybody so please
welcome the host of american ninja
warrior on nbc
matt eiseman and akbar bianca
so how does this game go well this game
is going to be pretty good so akbar and
i have eight cases here
inside these cases are secret items
now kelly and emily will each take turns
choosing a case
akbar and i will then open the case and
use the item inside of them
as quietly oh that's possible
first person to buzz in and correctly
guess
what the item is okay based just
on its sound gets the point you just do
a line
and skills are allowed in this game so
okay it's time to play steals are
allowed a quiet case
okay so i'm ready here's everybody here
tkcs that's kelly clarkson show for our
new guest
nice guests go first emily oh you choose
your case
six i was already ready and i was like
doing anything
okay so we're not going to don't look
over here don't you cheat blunt
i'm known for it i will not play a game
with the cheater
you guys ready you do it
we saw the light first emily you buzzed
in a soda
yes great job i'm going on
in my defense i thought the noise before
the can of soda would be part of it
yeah and i was rummaging around with
something i was like is that pebbles is
that
i have to try to figure it out i would
have answered a can of beer that would
have been acceptable but now
okay i am picking two okay
oh man okay okay that's a loser number
okay
oh she's talking trash she's letting you
know the person i see blood trying to
catch a secret
i did i didn't i probably are you guys
ready yeah okay
here we go okay whoa
how did you know that so fast brush do
it again not a brush
hold on hold on if you don't get after
this you will be shamed
it's just not packing up christmas
christmas
christmas
cheating is if you don't get it with
this
don't shame me for being hungry in the
middle of an intense game
all right here we go all right so
offended by chris
emily you're up five five let's go
damn wait i see blood trying to catch me
no no no no no no no no no
all right here we go here we go
it sounds the same
brush
are you okay did you brush your hair
today
don't look i can't see anything i can't
i
can't we need a guest emily
say bruh you could think of something
that was invented in outer space
perhaps
what is that it's called velcro oh that
did not sound like that
the rip it the judge's rulings are final
in the score right now
i didn't emily two points kelly you have
yet to get on the board
i'm sorry we're getting a report here
the judges have made a switch they're
saying this one
is worth no no no yes five points
yeah wait it's actually kelly telling me
this i'm hearing her voice
thank you so much thank you matt choose
your case
okay oh i choose the case you choose one
because i am numero uno
except not with this because that's a
brush it would be so good if it's a
brush
everything sounds like a brush ladies
are you ready everything sounds like
five points at stake pebbles whichever
one gets helps
will be our champion pebbles brushes
pedals
it fits emily pebbles
pounding rocks kelly you need to get
this correct i want to hear again
it's not a breath okay once again we
will give you
the same oh i know what it is can i see
what it is
can i go again can i go again is it like
a
can i go again can i hear it again again
okay one second
no you can't go again you haven't
yourself don't give her any more clues
because i know what it is don't do it
here we go kevin i know she's listening
carefully no she's had enough and you
cannot
cannot guess emily blunt's voice
although we are hearing that right now
i mean i heard like a piece here we go
kelly
i will not sleep tonight if i accept
this as a win
but emily please don't i will not accept
i did not accept this way
to be fair he ate the potato chips he
ate the potato chips
he did but still emily wins the game i'm
a fair person
i'm a fair person all right thank you
guys for playing
um and you know what screw you all for
not having a brush whatever
you can see emily in a quiet place part
two in theaters may 28th
and in jungle cruise which i'm stoked
about in theaters later this summer
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help